أنت تعرف ما هو مدهش بالنسبة لي
من نواح كثيرة حول شركتك
ونوع المرونة التي
تحاول توفيرها للشركات في هذه
اللحظة ليس فقط أن لديك
نظرة ثاقبة حول المكان الذي يعمل فيه
العاملون من الأشخاص ومن أين ولكن أيضًا بشكل
شخصي لأنك  لقد قرأت بعد
الوباء أن ثلثي القوى العاملة
لديك تم توظيفهم بالفعل ، أعني
أن هذا ضخم كما أنه يمنح
مشاهدينا إحساسًا بكيفية توسيع
نطاقك أيضًا كيف تبدو القوى العاملة
الآن وخاصة في الضوء
عن التوظيف الذي كنت تقوم به في
الآونة الأخيرة ، كيف تجري هذه
المحادثات وماذا
يريد الناس ،
إنه سؤال رائع وأعتقد أن
الشيء الوحيد الذي يريده الناس أكثر من
أي شيء آخر
هو المرونة ، لقد قمنا بمجموعة من
البحث مع مجموعة تسمى منتدى المستقبل
79 شخصًا يريدون المرونة في مكان
عملهم ولكن 94 شخصًا وهذا في المرتبة الثانية
بعد التعويض 94 يريدون المرونة في
وقت العمل وأعتقد أن القدرة
على الانتقال  بعض الأعمال المتزامنة
والعمل الذي يحدث مع عدة
أشخاص في نفس الوقت مثل
اجتماع للوسائل غير المتزامنة أمر
مهم للغاية وعندما يكون لدينا هذا
البديل فإنه يمنح الناس قدرًا هائلاً
من المرونة ، فإنه يمنح أصحاب العمل
مزيدًا من المرونة في التوظيف على نطاق أوسع.
المنطقة الجغرافية ونعم لقد ذكرت
أن ثلثي القوى العاملة لدينا قد
وظفت بعد انتشار الوباء في هذه المرحلة بالنسبة
لمعظم الشركات ، ستكون 20 30 50
كما تعلم أننا كنا في هذه الولاية
لمدة عامين وربع
أرباب العمل الذين
يختارون إنشاء شبكة أوسع في المكان الذي يوظفون فيه ،
أعتقد أنهم يتمتعون بميزة كبيرة ، حيث
لا يمكن تلبية طلب الموظفين على المرونة إلا من قبل أرباب العمل الذين
يرغبون في
الحصول على القليل من العقل المنفتح ، أعني
أنه لا يزال هناك  مجموعة كبيرة جدًا
من الأشخاص الذين لديهم هذا الاعتقاد بأنه في
وقت ما قريبًا ستعرف 90 يومًا من
الآن في أي نقطة معينة ،
سنعود إلى ما كانت عليه الأمور تمامًا
ومن الواضح أن  سيحدث بالفعل ،
لقد كان هناك الكثير هناك ، أحاول
أن أقرر ما سأطلبه منك بعد ذلك ، لقد
ذكرت شيئًا مهمًا حقًا
أعتقد وهو أنك توظف في
أماكن ليس لديك فيها
مكاتب وهذا هو  جزء حاسم من ذلك هو أنه
يجعل التوظيف أسهل ، فهو يجعله
أرخص للتعيين خاصةً عندما
ننظر حول العالم لظروف
سوق العمل شديدة الضيق ، فهو سوق عمل شديد الضيق ،
لذلك لا يتعلق الأمر بالتوفير في التكاليف ،
إنه حقًا  حول التوسيع ، فأنت
تعلم أننا مررنا بعقد بالإضافة إلى
منافسة شديدة الصعوبة
لتوظيف عمال التكنولوجيا وبغض
النظر عما يحدث في البيئة الكلية ،
لا أرى ذلك يتغير لمجرد أن
التكنولوجيا أصبحت عنصرًا أكبر
في الخدمات المالية للرعاية
الصحية  من البيع بالتجزئة ، لذلك يقوم الجميع بتوظيف
عاملين في مجال التكنولوجيا
،
لقد أدركنا أنه ربما في صيف
عام 2020 هو
أننا نوظف كل هؤلاء الأشخاص في أماكن
ليس لدينا مكاتب ،
ونخبر الموظفين الذين يعملون بها  في نيويورك ، سان
فرانسيسكو ،
طوكيو ، تورنتو ، فانكوفر ، الأماكن
التي لدينا فيها مكاتب
يسمح لهم بنقل العديد
منها ، كما تعلمون ، ساعات أو في
بعض الحالات أبعد من ذلك بكثير من أجل الحصول
على منزل أكبر ليكون أقرب إلى الأسرة أو
أي شيء آخر  كانت احتياجاتهم هي أننا لا نستطيع أن نطلب
منهم العودة ، لذا فإن فكرة بقاء
الأشخاص في المكتب لمدة
يومين في الأسبوع ليست
منطقية حقًا إلا إذا كنت
ستقيد
المجموعة المحتملة من  موظفين إلى أولئك
الذين يعيشون على مسافة تنقل
من أحد مكاتبك وهذا سيكون من
الحماقة